ya que hemos estado hablando acerca de
como las estrellas se formaron y la
evolución de las estrellas
pensé que era tiempo de que viéramos
algunas fotos de estrellas o de
estrellas en formación o de la evolución
de las estrellas esta foto es de la
nebulosa del águila la nebulosa del
águila y solo para que sepas la palabra
nebulosa es una palabra general para
cualquier nube de gas o polvo
interestelar así que cuando estamos
hablando de la nebulosa del águila en
realidad estamos hablando de una
nebulosa enorme y de hecho es una
nebulosa que se está expandiendo y solo
para que tengas una noción este es sólo
uno de los pilares de los llamados
pilares de la creación probablemente ya
has visto la imagen de los tres pilares
antes esto es sólo una pequeña parte de
la nebulosa del águila y solo este pilar
de aquí justo este pilar solo para que
tengas una idea de lo grande que es
solamente este pilar es de siete años
luz
de siete años luz de largo
esta es una distancia enorme recuerda la
distancia de la tierra a la estrella más
cercana es de unos cuatro años luz al
boi ayer le tomaría si se coloca en la
dirección correcta viajando a 60 mil
kilómetros por hora le tomaría 80 mil
años para atravesar cuatro años luz solo
este pilar es de siete años luz y quería
mostrarte esto porque este tipo de
nebulosas son el lugar en el que pueden
formarse estrellas por lo que justo aquí
tenemos un semillero para el nacimiento
de nuevas estrellas este gas se condensa
hasta que llega a una temperatura
crítica y a una densidad crítica en
donde se puede obtener fusión de
hidrógeno así que esto es sólo una
enorme nube interestelar de gas
hidrógeno que es un caldo de cultivo
para estrellas
y de hecho pensamos que esta nebulosa ya
ni siquiera existe porque recuerda esto
está muy muy lejos de nosotros está a
siete mil años luz de distancia de
nosotros siete mil años luz de distancia
esto significa que lo que estamos viendo
ahora los fotones que están llegando a
nuestros ojos oa nuestros telescopios en
este momento dejaron esta región del
espacio hace siete mil años por lo que
lo estamos viendo como era hace siete
mil años así que una gran cantidad de
este gas una buena parte de este
hidrógeno podría ya haberse condensado
en muchas muchas más estrellas por lo
que puede que ya no se vea de esta forma
en este momento y de hecho ocurrió una
supernova que pensamos pudo haber volado
una buena parte de esta nebulosa y no
vamos a poder ver los efectos de esta
supernova por otros mil años pero en fin
esto es una fotografía bastante
impresionante en mi opinión y esa
hermosa a cualquier escala pero es aún
más alucinante cuando piensas que se
trata de una estructura de siete años
luz de altura y esto es sólo una parte
de la nebulosa del águila uno de los
pilares de la creación aquí tenemos un
campo de estrellas y esta es una vista
hacia el centro de nuestra galaxia la
vía láctea
esta es la constelación de sagitario lo
bello de esto es que se ve tal
diversidad de estrellas esto es también
bastante increíble porque cada una de
estas estrellas se encuentran dentro de
nuestra galaxia
esto es una vista hacia el centro de
nuestra galaxia esta no es una de esas
imágenes en las que estamos mirando más
allá de nuestra galaxia o mirando
cúmulos de galaxias aquí sólo estamos
viendo estrellas y estamos viendo una
gran variedad de ellas vemos algunas
estrellas que brillan en rojo por aquí y
bueno no podemos saber por esta imagen
el tamaño de las estrellas ya que se
encuentran a distancias diferentes y
brillan con
en ciudades diferentes pero las
estrellas más rojas estas se encuentran
en su fase de gigante roja o mejor dicho
es probable que estén en su fase de
gigante roja no he hecho una
investigación específica sobre estas
estrellas pero eso es lo que sospechamos
que se encuentran en su fase de gigante
roja las que están en la parte de color
blanco amarillento del espectro estas
son estrellas que están probablemente en
su secuencia principal probablemente no
sean muy diferentes de nuestro sol las
que están en la parte de color naranja
amarillo blanco del espectro y las que
se ven de color un poco más a su lado o
un poco más de color verdoso estos están
quemando súper rápido déjenme ver si
puedo encontrar una esto se ve un poco
azulada estas se están quemando super
súper rápido y así las estrellas super
masivas se queman de manera rápida y
furiosa y luego simplemente desaparecen
mientras que las estrellas más pequeñas
las que tienen menor masa se queman más
lentamente durante un periodo de tiempo
mucho mucho más largo las que se están
quemando súper rápido están emitiendo
una gran cantidad de energía en la parte
de longitud de onda más pequeña del
espectro de luz es por eso que se ven
más azules o verdes y estas son las
estrellas más masivas las que se ven de
color blanco o azulado o verde mientras
que las más rojas son estrellas menos
masivas que se encuentran en su fase de
supergigante por lo que son más frías
que las estrellas en su secuencia
principal
este de aquí es la nebulosa ojo de gato
y esta es en realidad una nebulosa
planetaria esta de aquí es una nebulosa
planetaria
y se llama una nebulosa porque es una
especie de gas que está flotando en el
espacio pero es un tipo completamente
diferente de la nebulosa del águila que
tenemos aquí cuando la gente habla de
nebulosas normalmente están hablando de
algo así como la nebulosa del águila de
estas enormes masas de gas interestelar
y cuando se habla de las nebulosas
planetarias esto todavía tiene un radio
enorme pero no está cerca de siete años
luz
este es el subproducto de una estrella
deshaciéndose de todo su material
exterior al centro de esta imagen vemos
una estrella madura aquí y se deshizo de
sus capas exteriores y lo hizo durante
su fase de gigante roja el núcleo se
mantendría estallando teniendo estas
explosiones calientes y cada vez que
tenía una de estas explosiones sus capas
exteriores eran empujadas hacia afuera
empujadas hacia el espacio formando esta
nebulosa planetaria por lo que esta
nebulosa como lo vemos en este momento
todavía
no es una enana blanca sigue siendo una
estrella activa sigue habiendo fusión en
esta estrella pero está en camino a
convertirse en una enana blanca una vez
que todo su combustible se agote ya pasó
su fase de gigante roja ya arrojó todo
este material al espacio y está en
camino a convertirse en una enana blanca
espero que lo hayas disfrutado todas
estas imágenes me parecen bastante
cautivadoras especialmente la del campo
de estrellas porque todo esto está
dentro de nuestra galaxia espero que
esto te ayude a apreciar el número de
estrellas que hay esto es sólo una
pequeña fracción de los 200 a 400 mil
millones de estrellas dentro de la vía
láctea